[Music]
this past summer we were fortunate
enough to team up with bud light seltzer
again we got this not an ad we were
asked to do some content for bud light
seltzer and i thought well do my um my
classic bit to my classic pratfall that
i've been doing
since
uh kindergarten i think it was something
i think i learned from either laurel and
hardy or charlie chaplin or one of those
greats it's your bit now yeah i adopted
it and um i've taken good care of it
over the years you have to stop the door
with your foot and then you whip your
head back as though
you're revealing your secret
david copperfield i was doing that bit
for this bud light selter content i
thought why not i pretended to walk into
this bud light sign
i made the a crucial error which was i
was wearing crocs
i think i might have broken my toe when
i did it just trying to do a funny the
joke was on me because for the next two
weeks i was hobbling and i didn't know
how to tell people
what had really happened you should tell
your children that it's an old football
injury oh i'm going to yeah not that you
kicked a cement block wearing crocs
yeah i kicked the game-winning field
goal
but that's that's as far as my football
imagination goes i'd just be a kicker
my kids wouldn't believe anything
hopefully they wouldn't believe you have
realistic football ambitions
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short i'm
your realistic dreamer host justin long
life could be a dream
[Music]
and with me as always is my fellow croc
wearing co-host and brother do you like
it
no no but you often do generally uh
often well
what eight percent of the time
eight percent of my foot where you're
suggesting anything crop
oh really no oh i would say that's true
of me oh i'd say less than
one percent oh oh oh okay so when you're
up at the lake you don't wear crocs like
most of the time
oh i guess i do too and you're up there
a lot all right care to remind
they'd be a great sponsor can we just
start like is that pathetic you know we
just start like trying to court sponsors
no no i like that idea you know crocs
have got did you know this about crocs
they've gotten a whole new life recently
i know you know why justin bieber yeah
right we should tell the story about our
justin bieber encounter
um yeah maybe save it
yeah why not okay um i know crocs he
that's he can make anything popular
justin is that amazing they were they
were such a joke for so long i know same
with uh and then he wears them and
they're cool there's a whole new
like line of them amazing he's a true
trendsetter taste maker yes you know i
had a crazy dream about pete davidson
the other night um
and about what a that he has a huge we
have to cut this out but it's just that
he has such a big dick
he does
that's what the speculation is just
because he gets a lot of girls yeah
that's stupid anyway i don't know i
don't i don't i don't buy that really he
doesn't look like he would yeah but but
i don't i don't like girls i don't buy
the connection that because he dates a
lot of famous people therefore he has a
large penis what does that have to do
with anything uh you should ask i'm not
saying a mansplain well i'm not saying
you'll have a large people i'm not
saying it's um i'm not saying
a little penis isn't a deterrent to
dating a lot of people yeah but i don't
think you're
dating a lot of people requires having a
huge penis so you think the worst he has
like a normal size yeah yeah yeah i
don't i definitely don't think he has a
small penis okay well
yeah that's pretty safe that's a safe
assumption right pretty safe um
why are we talking about um jokes and
pratfalls and in your professional your
potential professional sports career yes
yes well that got sidetracked
what would um i guess i'd be a kicker if
i played football yeah or a long snapper
no no no then i'd have to block oh
that's true imagine me trying to block
one of those guys
um anyway we're talking about jokes and
failed jokes and attempts at jokes
because um our guest today is one of the
best at jokes his jokes are uh
they're like works of art he's an artist
he's a jokey artist that's how much i
value what he does what he does wouldn't
you say like there's an artistic quality
to what they did of course um he is on a
show that we've talked about before on
this show called impractical jokers it
was something that we got really into
during quarantine
um i watched i just binged it
uh sal volcano one of the other jokers
on the show was previous guests yes now
friend of the show so this is our second
impractical joker to be on the show
hopefully we'll get all four yeah we
want to eventually the whole set it's
pretty good i'm excited for the second
one now yeah
and yeah like you said we
watched that show so much during the
lockdown that i felt like
we became friends with those guys i know
they're so i know i know i kind of hate
this word but relatable they're so
relatable yeah i had never met him truly
felt like i have i think hopefully
you'll hear it um
he's just so
easy going and he's a guy that like you
know i was just talking to christian
about how i took the long island ferry
for the first time and um he's a guy
that you just run into i think that's
their appeal you run into him anywhere
on the phone oh yeah i saw you in line
at the ferry you said long island ferry
oh what is it uh fairy i just wanted to
clarify because you kind of stumbled
over the long island part of it okay
i'm i'm tempted to ask misha to cut that
but maybe it's funny i think it's funny
because it's at my expense
yeah that's why i want it cut isn't that
that's arrogant i should not have and i
and i want it not cut because it's funny
that it's at you yeah yes which is a
little mean no it's not yeah i think it
makes for good uh comedy it's funny i
should not have that kind of ego that
somewhat so i trip over words so i'm a
pot so i'm a professional podcast host
who trips over words
yeah but it's natural i think people
like um
you know maybe well we leave
warts and all farts and all right um
anyway speaking of farts and funny
things um our guest today i don't think
we've even said his name yet we haven't
i don't think so oh my god this might be
the longest we've gone without saying it
drumroll please
uh his name is joe gatto
gatto gato uh which means great name
well i think it means cat
in spanish you know who would like that
name bill burr
you know he likes a regular name i bet
he's joe billy yeah yeah nice strong
name joe gatto yeah bill did a thing
christian i made a christian like a
birthday video and bill did a bit for it
and he was like
what are your parents naming you these
names christian justin what about good
strong like yeah what do you say like
like tim i guess timmy billy mikey joey
yeah
let's get into it
all right we got a good strong name for
a good funny guest uh one of my one of
the funniest to me a god i love him and
his
uh fellow jokers
here he is i hope you feel the same way
the uh also such a nice guy you're about
to hear him why do you want to hear me
talk about it more let them judge for
themselves yes uh okay judges put on
your white wigs and take out your gavels
here he is
the uh impractically funny no sure
joe gatto life could be a dream
sweetheart
[Music]
are we doing this with the masks on oh
no i don't know i should take it i know
yeah um yeah i'm backstage
oh i'm not at all no i'm uh i have
several variants great um i brought my
own again
i need the delta one full assortment i
came in we'll cut this out we shouldn't
be doing i mean
it's too soon maybe do you think so i
don't know maybe maybe not for you
okay yeah oh it's great
katie's offering joe a lot i walked into
a whirlwind of beverage options that i
was not prepared for okay i'm so curious
i will say that i did recently have a
coffee but didn't want when i heard you
sold it you said it was an ice-cold
latte yes that's what's sold ice cold
got it yeah yeah i had a coffee as well
but oh la colombe i noticed you got you
got we do the same thing um you love
free stuff you love mentioning yeah i'm
all over the place
what do you got i'll endorse it give me
it i don't even care what it is i i just
i honestly like
i like the part of being able to help
brands which is fun yeah for me too
which is cool and sometimes the story is
a line but sometimes they don't and
sometimes just so often because i'm like
i'm like a vegetarian vegan kind of
thing that's true so like all the meat
all the fake meats came at me all the
plant base was like this is our boy this
is our horse in the comedy world thank
you so much yeah because they're not
many thank you katie thank you oh okay
yeah colombia i've i've had these really
yes and they're fantastic i think the
ice cold is really what sold it too it's
nice it gives it a nice little touch you
know what's nice i usually avoid these
things because they're a little sweet
for me i
this is not too sweet six grams of
sugar
um but wait what how long have you been
vegan i was i became vegetarian four
years ago
and then i went
full veg
i tried uh
i i went uh and and i
i dip in and out of pescatarian and
vegan now what what is it about fish
what fish are you do you have a hard
time avoiding i love a good shellfish
like a good seafood tower anywhere yeah
you got me i'm in crab leg that kind of
stuff uh even like a sushi like a sushi
you know so i do that i want to you know
when i come out here it's always hard
because of my favorite sushi places are
out here joe you do a lot of uh animal
rescue chairs animal rescue work is it
was that the impetus for yeah that was
by the way not a fart i'd like to point
out yeah i know this is the chair this
is the one i got yeah not that you would
care you'd seem like no i'll i'll let
you know because we're in a small room
and i'll let you know but i'm not i'm
i'm all right i've been doing okay
so far the la
before i got here so everything's fine
oh good i meant to ask you okay i don't
have to ask it was my second question
when and how was your last bm
covered that was fantastic check that
off isn't that i've heard you guys talk
about that actually i think or maybe it
was sal when he was on the show there's
something about now bats just taking it
just having the best nice
and when you know it throws you off i'm
notorious though um
i get woken up in the middle like my
wife gets very annoyed because like 3am
i'll wake up and i'll have to go to the
bathroom oh really and number two yeah
we sleep with six dogs in my bed i have
nine dogs so i sleep with six of them in
my bed so it's definitely like a jigsaw
puzzle like to try to get out and in
back in bed so it's
without waking up the dogs yeah oh my
because then they'll wake her up yeah
they'll wake up everybody they do they
do all right they now they know i think
they're on the same time
and they all get up to poo
we all go down the dog run
no one's there probably three a.m
you just have to run to the place yeah
is that hard for your wife is she a
vegetarian she is vegetarian yeah she is
uh she's not vegan she she does a lot of
vegan stuff but mostly cheeses are hard
for her
um we don't eat eggs though but i i went
to an event that uh so impressive i went
to an event which really changed my life
called thanks living it's this place
called woodstock farm sanctuary who i
work with and i love them my wife took
me this event
and they do a reverse where you feed the
turkeys on their farm oh and then they
serve a full vegan meal oh that's cool i
met uh this 800 pound
male
milk cow basically which don't really
exist because they become veal oh yeah
and because they don't serve any purpose
so uh i met this beautiful beast called
caesar and he walked in and it was like
a
9 foot 800 pound dog super gentle super
sweet and i was like oh my god this
guy's great and then i wasn't really a
big meat eater anyway i did like some
chicken stuff but then i was like i
could probably do it and then i just did
it it was that unbelievable yeah it was
coming face to face come to face face
with it and then i saw the movie um
i saw a vegan movie which you're going
to have to insert the name of it later
yeah i've got the name of it
it'll come back to me there's one called
earthlings that i was on it was about
three years ago
it was called uh
mythbusters yeah let's say that yeah and
uh it was like talked about like all the
health benefits of vegan it really
wasn't about the animals and whatnot but
i always ate like such a disgusting
human and it was like the science behind
proving like you could actually say put
some years back on the clock if like you
tried it that's really compelling so i
tried it for like a week and i got
through it and i was like let me try
another week and then i honestly felt
the healthiest i've felt my adult life
really and i was like oh wow i should
try this for a minute i did that for
about a year and a half
then i got uh i missed desserts i was
gonna say because you're the hardest
part i you're a huge dessert guy i mean
it's like you've worked it into the show
well yeah it's now it's a business
expense
that's right oh my god so they come they
come to you to promote stuff like that
yeah yeah i get that all the time too
yeah oh i bad i bet because you're
constant for those of you
first of all if you haven't seen in
practical jokers we talk about it a lot
on the show so if people haven't been
annoyed by us enough to
give it a shot um i would again urge you
to see it it is so funny but um
but yeah that's you're constantly eating
on the show and i i noticed that you had
lost weight um a considerable amount of
weight and was that that was the vegan
well a little bit of mix of everything
because i was up to 225 at my heaviest
oh wow and i was like i i have two kids
and i was like i might want to stick
around for a little bit i should do
something here yeah and so i just
basically was portion controllable more
so for me because i always was like i
grew up in a big italian household to
finish a plate you know that whole thing
and i'd be full and i'd be still eating
the other half of the sandwich and i was
like i one day i was just like maybe
i'll just stop eating when i'm falling
yeah and it was unbelievable the change
and that oh when i stopped like trying i
cut out everything drinking besides
coffee and water i used to drink like a
lot of sodas and teas and lemonades and
that's that sort of stuff um i don't
drink alcohol so that wasn't a f ever
never been drunk and never tried a
cigarette or a drug in my life you're
kidding yes yeah it's all natural crazy
oh my god well now i'm like so curious
to see you on a drug i know that's what
everybody says oh my god why was that
what was that choice what was behind
that choice um i was real geeky growing
up never really got into it uh-huh um
when i was uh 18 my father had gotten
sick and uh he passed away when i was
19. he said to me oh i was a good guy i
didn't have to worry about i mean i
equated that to being like to drinking
and causing trouble so then for a couple
years it was like in my head like a
disappointment factor so interesting but
then i went to college and i was
everybody always thought i was drunk
because i was just crazy and fun like i
always had fun i didn't have to deal
with the hangovers i had more money i
always drove yeah
much more present you probably remember
and then everybody would come to me to
find out why they were in fights with
their girlfriends
you know like the morning news on friday
mornings was great with you
yeah yeah so it was like here's what you
did yeah she got upset with you wow
right but then i don't mind like i have
all my friends like drink you know i've
been with people like cute stuff yeah
yeah she enjoys a beer and now yeah you
know
yes i was a bartender for a while that's
right so like they i don't mind i love
drunk people i love being i could be
around them it's not like that thing
where i'm like oh like i'm not going to
club till 4am i don't care i'm just
having fun yeah that's so impressive
that's so admirable oh thanks
wow and you said you grew up in an
obviously big italian house
you have a lot of siblings then i have
two older sisters okay but i'm one of 15
cousins i'm the youngest of 15. oh my
god that's a crazy little and so you're
it was that on your dad's side that was
my mom's side okay yeah my dad's side he
he cut ties with because they fell to uh
they fell into some sort of mafioso
trouble we'll get to that okay yeah
let's save that my father's side my
father had one brother and he actually
uh he went on the lamb
down to uh he went on the lane i've
never known anyone who's gone on the
line yeah my uncle had gone on the lamb
he was it was like a small time of
running numbers on staten island oh my
god and he just took money from the
wrong people and then he just left and
went to dc and a guy not this is a true
story a guy knocked on my father's door
my parents were newlyweds they were
living in a one bedroom apartment on
staten island they're married one year
and a guy knocked on the door and he
says uh are you joe gatto yeah his
frankie brother and he says yeah he goes
you owe me whatever it was you owe me
five thousand dollars i was like i don't
have it he said i'm coming back every
day until you do so they called the
police whatever and they did a
full-blown fbi sting operation no and my
the fbi was hiding in my parents
bathroom of their one bedroom apartment
they got the guy in the kitchen again
we'll call his they got him talking the
guys bust out and they they arrested the
guy oh my god
wait a minute uh
wait so wasn't your dad nervous that
like to get involved did you get
involved at all no not real because he
knew my father like he knew he wasn't in
like any sort of big time wreck was all
like small time staten island like
trouble it wasn't like you know it
wasn't the main families i guess
but he wasn't just not he was also just
not gonna have it so he was like we
gotta solve this problem he wasn't gonna
he was that kind of guy yeah yeah
was he he must have been fun he must
have been funny he was
my dad's i had the everybody always says
that the best of my mom and my dad
because my dad
had the ability to just say something
just loud enough to make you laugh and
embarrass you because you're laughing
and nobody knows why you're laughing the
kingdom
but he was super he was kind of dry or
whatever but he was very funny and my
mother was super funny but electric
walked in the room let it up that kind
of deal is she still now she passed away
about nine years ago oh so but she was
here for the premiere oh and she was
like she was like the mom she was like
our mascot like you know second month
was her name her name was jerry jerry
she was we we actually used to rehearse
in her basement no
the tenderloins formed in the basement
of my mother's house i was that's right
i was crushing it living at home early
30s killing it uh but she used to
rehearse and she used to like come and
like just like in the other room there's
like an office she'd pretend to like pay
bills and just like listen and laugh so
cute so she was like our mascot and
stuff so it was great and she got to see
the premiere she was like a peacock all
over staten island you know like that's
my son
joe yes oh man that's really cool and
your sisters what do they do they're uh
they're awesome one i have two older
ones one is in jersey and she has um she
has older kids now um and then my other
one is out on long island with me and
she had she has 16 year old twins oh wow
and then she had a uh um accident baby
baby yeah a little joey is our whoopsie
baby and he's seven oh wow so they have
a six-year-old that's a nice bridge yeah
that's nice and you're close enough they
can hang out yeah them yeah and we're
super tight we're all together all the
time that's um how long was your uncle
on the land for is he still on the way
no he passed away three uh months after
my father oh my god they got him
oh my god
i don't even know how he went well i you
know it's funny i was uh thinking about
you in the context of um being able to
laugh about anything like we made
some jokes about i was making a joke
about uh a coveted variant and i thought
immediately felt like oh my god that's
too much i couldn't do and i remember i
was watching jerry seinfeld on comedians
and cars and he said you know comedians
they'll laugh at anything like that
that's their default you can he's like i
expect people to be laughing about
making jokes about me at my funeral um
and i remember
you laughing about your dad's passing
yeah on the show i remember the guys
kind of teasing you about it yeah yeah
and thinking jesus that's gotta be all
is that not off limits but you were like
good-natured about it i get them with it
more often than not
yeah like i have like i've brought in
one of the episodes i don't know if you
saw the one where i brought uh it's the
one where we're trying to make each
other left so there's a challenge where
we're trying to make each other laugh in
a waiting room in front of our other
people that wasn't bad
elimination so it was down to me and q
and i had a phone call and i was like oh
and i took a fake phone call i was like
hey oh you're here i thought i was
meeting you guys at the restaurant and i
was like oh okay i love you mom love you
dad and i hung up and i left and walked
out and i said i'll meet you and i said
i'll be right back and i walked in with
two skeletons on sticks
and they sat with me and q was literally
punching himself in his face not to
laugh uh does it count if you
how do you if you i've wondered that
about that particular challenge if you
contort your face i mean like you're
guitar you kinky
we have a gentleman's agreement that
laughs a laugh and you'll you'll admit
and surrender it's more of a surrender
thing like you know that somebody got
you okay because your thing is you you
kind of put your you have you each have
a specific way to like prevent laughter
i try to go dead in the eyes and just
hold my lips together like and that's
really my default
yeah what's the hardest because you also
seem well we'll get into it a little bit
but i um
there's so many things to ask you i feel
like
first of all i should say to people
listening
this is the first time that i've
seen
when we've recorded one of these i
haven't been in person with somebody
this is great this is great and i'm so
glad it's you joe because um i said this
to sal as well but um i discovered your
show like at the start of the pandemic
you know when we were like locked down
and quarantined and i just i felt like i
hung out with you for the first couple
of months it was the best it was such a
godsend um so it's really i don't know
it's really there's something very
symbolic about getting to do that's
great oh yeah it's so awesome yeah yeah
it's like like uh you're not sick of me
yet so not at all not at all in fact i
am i'm so glad that the new season that
i've been working in in bulgaria and i
haven't had a chance to
see the new season i saw the first
episode um but uh and i want to get in i
want to get into it and the challenges
that the quarantine has presented in
terms of doing
has there have there been anything that
like you found it's been a if anything
like a benefit uh to doing it in this
new environment yeah i think we've had
to really concentrate on new ways to do
it which is fun which is you know you
don't really think of new ways to do
when you come to season nine right like
if she's an awesome is like good we got
it well it's also like works i mean like
even the challenge you you you mentioned
like make each other laugh in a waiting
room it's simple but it's like still
you're still mining such great stuff
think about all the time you try to make
your friends laugh like you do you can
make it you know you do it every day or
the names or like i love when you answer
the phone you have to like
ask for people's names in a waiting room
um without laughing without laughing
it's so good and and just silly names
really make me laugh and that's one of
the ones you're not quite as good at i
feel like your strength is
um you're you seem fearless yes boldness
is really one yeah because the thing
with this comedy that we do is like the
way i naturally made my friends laugh
like these guys were always like sal was
always afraid to like get an elevator
with me just because he knew something
was gonna go down like the subway like
anything close face with me he would
just like hate you know because he knew
something was gonna happen but like it's
gonna take delight you're the one that
like especially with sal
like his fear of cats let's say i mean
he's like a death like a real
deep fear and yeah he does do you have
this this look of glee sometimes when i
i watch it sometimes that i'm cringing
on sal's behalf but it's you know
obviously fun um but you always seem
like you really take joy yeah yeah i i
do because sal wears it on his skin and
south is a thing where he uh enjoys the
torture a bit with when his friends are
doing it like he does that thing where
he's like stop yeah you know what's
happening but i've always like sal's
always been such a fun target for me
we've been through so much together um
you know and
it
i've always i've always had a bunch of
long comms with him and my favorite one
it actually got discovered when we were
filming the pilot of the tv show
for year for a decade full decade any
mailing list i came across i would put
cell's phone number and email on
like think about how many mailing lists
back in the day right i'm talking about
like you know late late 90s right like
everybody wants your email just one i'd
put everything so sal used to get stacks
of junk mail to his house like he
literally once got uh
literally once he got a i signed him up
for the uh
the ex
i've got the name of the pack i'm going
to say executive but it was like the
executive sample package for
tempur-pedic mattresses
and oh no the craftmatic adjustable bed
oh yeah and they sent him a they sent
him a mini to his house like a mini
version of the
like they wanted to like show him how it
worked and he would just have stays
stacks of it did he know right away he
knew right away he had no idea was me oh
really a decade right so what we're
filming that we're filming the tv show
that's patience yeah we're filming the
tv show and we're at the and i'm not
even there for the payoff for most of it
right no that's crazy so i'm at i'm at
the uh we're at a bar and and then the
shot girl is going around she's like go
sign up for our mailing list second
nature i just grabbed and started
filling it in and sal walks over and he
looks down and he sees his email he's
like hey what's up and it was like a
kaiser sose moment oh right here right i
was in a barbershop quartet
illinois he starts putting it together
together and then he turns around and he
goes oh
and he literally goes the craftmatic
that from years earlier
so it was like 10 and then he just we i
he
laughed for about 20 minutes i couldn't
get me off the floor that bar my best
fantastic but then did you want to know
all the reactions to all the other
things well no we got into like a
conversation yeah yeah
but he just he had so many questions
like how did you he must have been
stunned he must have been stunned that
you
just the patience yeah that you must
also like he must have been i'm
picturing sag because i know i'm a
little bad i love sound like there must
have been like a mix of like admiration
and confusion like just that sound has
that that's a big like there's a that's
a big part of the show especially yeah
murders like that too like if you pull
something off it's like bravo because it
says you're so torn you're like twisty
like all these sons they got me and
they're like that's my boys right right
but it's like i gotta go i gotta respect
it yeah
how you guys have known each other since
high school right
over 30 years at this point wow wow and
uh it makes sense i mean you seem like
you all really love each other has has
there been anything oh on the show where
it crossed a lot i mean have you crossed
lines on the show not really like
because we're friends at the end of the
day too like there'll be some times
where
well being able to say no like you could
like it's tv too right so you could tell
why somebody's saying no somebody's
saying no because they don't think it's
right for us to do or whatever like so
we might we keep each other in check
it's like yeah it's like it's like us
producing ourselves okay okay it's like
nah we shouldn't do that and the guys in
the back are like no like tell me
oh yeah do that i'm like no no no who's
the who's the quickest to say no
um
i feel like you'd be the last to say
yeah me and q were probably the last
dish to say no murray's pretty bold too
i i think so at this point though like
you get used to it right it's kind of
like right always getting like every
time you shake hands you you get a
little static electricity shock you
still shake hands like oh here comes the
shock yeah like you feel like you get a
little that's true into it and and i
noticed that sometimes like it must be
no just psychologically knowing that
it's being filmed yes it must embolden
you a little bit yeah are you alive
perfect example me and me were just in
ralph's two nights ago we went to pick
up a sheet cake to bring over to a
friend's house
as a joke and uh we we were in the
supermarket and for the first time and i
just started like standing close to
people and like i had my you know my
mess on something i just started being
like shopping like right as they were
putting stuff down just to mess with
them while we were waiting yeah and
murray was getting so nervous and i
turned away i said because i hate being
out with you in public i haven't been
out with you in public
and i said well it's because it's the
first time we've been in a supermarket
without a camera you can't just like oh
we're filming yeah that's true there's
no
there's like no security
yeah so it was really interesting he's
like oh i can't go out with you in
public we're not filming that's so funny
and and he uh that's so you just do that
naturally yeah like this one was
shopping with the cheeses and when she
had one up i was like nah like tell him
like that was the wrong way she looked
at me like no not that one
she was like i just like for no reason i
bolted myself to help her with her
choices in the cheese well that's what
you do so well i you've taught me this
lesson which is um or you've really
solidified it which is if you say
something with confidence if you really
mean it you say like you mean it you can
kind of get away
with anything conviction you have
total conviction for sure yeah it's a
real
strength i mean where do you think that
came from i mean was it your dad yeah my
my parents for sure
i got a little bit of that but i think
also
experience right yeah i'm also i was in
sales for a long time
that makes sense that's so funny my
brother wrote that down he said yeah one
we wondered if you had a background yes
i did sales was my sales in my gym i
moved out here to chase the dream in
03.05 to become a screenwriter i ended
up working at nordstrom's at the grove
platinum pacesetter i don't want to
brag
it was just like i just fell into sales
and then
after like my i have accounting degree i
got into consulting and then after that
uh i got into like independent
filmmaking on the side and i fell in
love with it really so i left the whole
business part of it i moved out here to
to uh to choose that stream yeah so from
all through to o5 i lived out here for
two years to produce
yeah to write and direct oh no kidding
did you how did that go uh it was great
i wrote a couple things
and then i moved back home because my
grandmother passed away and my
grandmother and my mother became uh
widows together so then my mother was
truly alone so i went home and i was
like out there i was like hugging her at
the you know the funeral i was like you
know i was like maybe i'll move back for
a minute like just saying it out loud
and she was like oh my god thank you and
hug me and cry i'm like okay sounds like
i'm coming back oh you floated i did
yeah but it was good because i came back
and then the tenderloins yeah we re com
you know reconnected and oh that's why
so so there had been a few years where
you guys were off doing earth
when i lived out here when i came home
we used to put up shows and i would be
home every couple months you know to you
know check in with the family christmas
time whatever we throw up like we always
self-produce our own improv shows in
manhattan so we would throw a show up oh
and then after i moved back home we
moved into sketch comedy on the internet
it got big that's you know like myspace
and yeah so we started doing that kind
of thing and that's how we transitioned
into and and and what was the hidden
camera element how did that get
introduced that we just decided to film
what made to making each other laugh oh
yeah that wasn't it before a meeting
with true tv yeah so true tv was they
were like uh
murr was inside the develop murray was
like a a permanent temp for a while so
he worked at a much different job then
he landed a gig at the production
company that we work with north south
and he became their uh he worked in
development and he had heard whispers
about like people were looking for a new
type of you know prank show was like the
thing prank prank kind of deal and he
was like uh he's like hey let's think
about what our version of that would be
and we were just like we always get each
other like make each other laugh like
let's just film it so we literally took
our our iphones and just went and did it
like i stood in at time i went to times
square and there was a tyler perry
presents movie and i had to announce
everybody that i farted and i stood up
and i just owned it and it was like
insanity and like
so we just did all these like stupid
things and a sizzle girl came together
in the theater in the theater right
after previews i stood up and packed
theater tyler and people people started
applauding for me as i excuse myself
because i had bad mexican it was
fantastic
[Music]
daily use of plus cbd sleep garments get
you the rest you need so you can wake up
feeling focused and refreshed
we've talked about this before they're
formulated by a team of medical experts
and doctors they taste great they're
gummies they really do and they're made
with award-winning cbd combined with
melatonin magnolia bark lemon balm my
favorite balm all the things that you
need for a better sleep i love these
products oof they are
we both had one last night i had two
okay i had one and um they
really do
the trick
do they ever hey um we had a very
relaxing yes enjoyable
but i'm gonna stress relaxing or as
bachelorette contestants might say
relaxing relaxing
by the way woke up without any feeling
of like no
lethargy none it's they're the best yeah
the calm the calm gummies are great
sleep gummies are great and the ones
that combine have a little thc have 2.5
milligrams of thc which is what we had
last night who i dipped into i had five
milligrams wow not to brag this is a
great company visit plus cbd oil.com and
enter promo code long for 40 off your
order can you smell me i'm raising my
armpit in front of christians you smell
delicious yeah can you smell me no i
can't and i probably because you just
applied native deodorant to your skin
and you hadn't even showered don't
reveal that to everybody i've been
trying so many i've tried a lot of other
like natural deodorants ever since i
found out how sensitive that area of
your body really is i've tried to switch
over to a natural brand and i got to say
i've tried a lot of them
i am even if they weren't paying us to
do this even if this weren't an ad i'm a
native
customer for life now i'm a convert too
yeah fully i i mean like the eucalyptus
mint is great i love that smell oh man
the coconut is one of my favorites
there's a lavender yes and you know what
it is it's subtle they're not like
perfumey pungent uh
odors you know you know it's exciting
native now has new seasonal scents i
can't wait to try these
holiday sense oh cool like cane candy
cane they have
sugar cookies oh my god fresh mistletoe
imagine going to the gym and smelling
like a sugar cookie oh man i'm jealous
people will be i'm just gonna want to
eat guys armpits native deodorant is
formulated with ingredients you have
actually heard of like coconut oil shea
butter
their deodorant never uses aluminum
parabens sulfates any any of that bad
stuff but this is a big part but they
still keep you smelling amazingly fresh
all day long you never have to reapply
keep the sense of the season with you
and with natives limited time holiday
scented deodorants go to
nativedeodorant.com
and use code long to get 20 off your
first purchase at checkout that's
nativedeodorant.com
long for 20 off nativedeodorant.com
code long
hello hello again
[Music]
if the only thing i don't do and why our
show works is i don't like making people
feel bad for comedy right your show is
making friends feel bad so like there'll
be times in the beginning when we're
getting used to and getting our feet
like we'd like
like we did something like oh this is
that's not right this is something so we
were trying to calibrate it that's
interesting so the first seasons are a
little you know we got about through the
i would say the first half of the first
season we finally like oh okay that's it
this is it that's interesting you feel
weird and the people either confused or
like this guy's crazy like that's the
reactions we want we're not trying to
get people angry we're not there are
earlier episodes i'm thinking of where
it's borderline where it's like yeah not
that it's directly at somebody's expense
but it's dancing around with it yeah but
you guys do things like i'm imagining
now like just taking the cigarettes out
of people's mouths and like yeah there
are things that are are potentially
really like dangerous yes too and then i
mean we turn that and be like yeah we're
taking care of your health yeah i may be
a stranger but i'm worried about your
health yes so it kind of was like oh
that makes sense but no you're not
allowed to do that like saying like a
weird dynamic you play with the this is
what i love about this is because
there's there's such a fine line that
separates
chaos and weirdness from like the normal
rules of society like the societal rules
that we all agree on and if you just
what you guys do so well is like you
just kind of [ __ ] with those rules a
little bit you like twitch turn the dial
turn the dial just a little bit i'm
picturing you with the mashed potatoes
that they're serving the potatoes yeah i
mean i made it perfectly normal that a
guy was walking around throwing potatoes
at the table people were like yeah i'll
take more like literally the people were
asking for more like right right so sal
was like that doesn't happen in real
life i'm like it happens if you make it
normal so that's really what we're just
trying to do we make the weird normal
and i think a lot of times the general
public is super surprised i think from a
social like experiment yeah yeah they
people are so more on board to try stuff
than you think right because when they
have like permission to to like bend the
norm or be weird like it's like oh wow
this is this is fun oh let's try it yeah
yeah it's fun to play because most it
what you probably do for people is like
there is a mundane nature to going about
a day and like they have a story i mean
like there's nothing better than a good
story and like i'm picturing you in a
bikini washing that woman's car
phenomenal yeah this guy let me in to
vacuum like what are you doing for free
for free but that was a big thing i was
like no this is complimentary service
and the guy like is like oh yeah i want
my car wash but this guy's in a bikini
see i love
imagining people then retelling that
like how are they going to interpret
that and then go back to their friends
and be like their friends would be like
wait a bit you know like a full like oh
no two pieces
i came out purple
made his eyes look nice they popped was
he a model no no that was terrible
he should not be in any sort of that and
i guess it is about the personality mers
sometimes
gives off a different you know he has a
very different personality so when he's
doing something like i'm picturing
people leaving the parking lot having to
and he has to stall he has to like keep
them there
and that got a little dicey that's you
know because people don't when you mess
with people's time time yes time is a
big one for us right when you waste
people's time that aren't in the movie
but oh man uh what is your weakness
would you say in terms of being gotten i
don't like when it goes like the the
worst moment for me on the television
show hands down was the mets game i
don't know this one when i had to steal
ball people noah syndergaard who's uh
their one there
he used to say he was signing balls and
throwing him into he was in our pocket
he was our friend so he was signing
balls and throwing them into the crowd
but he just kept throwing into me and
there's a bunch of little kids oh it's
terrible and i had to and i had a fanny
pack and i just kept collecting them and
telling people i could go on ebay no so
there's this woman standing there who
really wants when she is holding her
two-year-old child oh no so i say to her
i said oh you really you want a bull
give me a kid so she gives me her kid
i'm like no well let's get one for the
baby noah and he knows and he throws it
they made me keep calling him jeter too
which was really funny so like jeter
cheaters nothing nothing like here at
all right so
not the same position but makes people
more upset because like you don't even
know like his name is noah i'm like just
jeter and always it's really funny so
she he throws me a ball and then i take
i grab it and i get the woman back her
baby and i put the ball in my fanny pack
and she goes give me that she goes wait
give me the ball and and i said oh you
could get it on ebay
and oh no she went nuclear oh like legit
the worst reaction hands down ask any of
us
embarrassing for her is there a moment
where you're like oh yeah yeah i was
like this is bad like yeah she's blurred
right she wouldn't sign the thing
she was like flipping out and she was
like it was one of those moments where
she screamed at the top how dare you
she's screaming at me and the whole
stadium gets quiet because it's before
the game so the whole scene is quiet and
looking at us now and you know what you
see i'm in my ear yeah i'm in my ear
it's dead silent because nobody knows
what to do i said what do we do here
boys quiet oh nobody my god so then i
said i was like
you gotta say here's the ball i gave her
the balls i was like uh okay i'm i'm
sorry i'm you know i'm sorry i'm i'm i'm
sorry you have to get on ebay and i like
walked away to get like the final joke
then the producers went up to her and
she like flipped out and she was like
what are you doing they ended up letting
her meet noah take pictures with them
like to soften the whole thing oh my god
it was hands down like it's the most
uncomfortable moment i think of the show
so even after that even if she got to do
a whole like song and dance with no
matter we didn't sign the thing yeah she
was that upset yeah
wow i'm so curious about that one but
then i was like she's got a kid i like
feel better she has a kid yeah but she
also gave her a kid to a man that she
doesn't know how to get a baseball right
i was like so i was like it's like i was
kind of weird so i didn't know i think
it just all happened so fast yeah so
that that moment of that was hands down
the most uncomfortable well that's a
good example of another thing i love
about the show is that it is so
revealing of human nature of human
behavior it's such a great study of yeah
you know i i'm you must encounter that
all the time and and it must make you
better at
walking in the world yeah you know
navigating navigating that the weirdness
of people and um wow i gotta see that i
can't believe that yeah you gotta make
sure you see that one that was wait is
it was that a new this new stuff was
like probably five season five oh my god
um are there ever times where you feel
we gotta pull the plug maybe on this
this is getting too like universal
studios queues worst moment hands down
with universal studios they do that tour
and we kept making them pull the
emergency brakes oh god that was crazy
so that was that's where i felt i felt
bad i was like we're in dangerous
territory right now because there's so
many people so many people there were
cars ahead of him that were like and he
was he was he played it perfectly he did
what he had to do um i love him for it
it's one of the best one of the best
questions we ever did but for for me
that's probably that's probably up there
with the baseball for me i bet that when
he had to pull that final one because he
had to say people's time like he said
and yeah and then we made that we made
the guy say hey because this guy's
wasting so much of our time we're gonna
have to skip a part of it oh that's
right and then that just made the whole
people on vacation
paying money to do this
who's on the show the friend of theirs
uh brian quinn is on a tram is on one of
those like universal tours
backlot tour and um he keeps pulling the
emergency stop like break but and for
not for like nonsense reasons yeah i
missed a picture could we go back yeah
there's like i miss what you said could
you say it
one of my favorite ones is we make a
pull it the guy comes over and says he
said i miss what you said could you say
it again he tells him what he said and
he goes away and then we make him pull
it right away and he comes back he goes
i just want to get off on the wrong foot
i'm sorry if i should be
so he apologizes for pulling it by
pulling it again
yeah that's right
brilliant uh and
is that stuff happening in the moment i
mean are you coming up with like in the
moment wow
we have some you know we have an idea we
have a framework that we go through but
a lot of it goes out the window yeah
when stuff starts happening i bet well
you got to like yeah that's where the
improv helps you know what's going on
it's like you just you dive in and yeah
we feed off each other somebody has an
idea you build you build your building
right yeah like i'm picturing when they
made you sneezy
sneeze against a wall you do it once
it's funny then they're like do it
bigger bigger bigger and it just goes i
mean they love me as a result
you're a good fake sneezer i'm a great
fake news yeah it's one of my one of my
strengths yeah not really good now in
the world but yeah i do i do a lot of uh
the receptionist gigs are always my they
can't they can't wait for me to go
you're amazing they love me as a
reception yes i think that i think the
hardest i probably made them laugh was
when i had to eat the i don't know if
you saw where they they replaced the
chair with a uh a workout ball you know
one of those yeah yes i saw that yeah
yeah and sal's turn he had had a turkey
sandwich and he threw it out in the
garbage and they said joe if you could
orchestrate to fall off the ball knock
down the knock down the garbage can and
eat the sandwich uh you win and i and i
didn't just kept saying nom nom nom nom
nom as i was eating and you heard them
they were around the corner of the
office
the woman heard them laughing throughout
i was literally going guys be quiet they
lost it yeah it was phenomenal what is
your dude what is the name that you
remember uh having a hard hardest time
not laughing at when when you're having
to read out names oh dr shrimp puerto
rico what is dr shrimp puerto rico is a
rough one yeah that's one of my favorite
names we've ever came up with dr puerto
rico it's great yeah yeah mother
coconuts is a fun one too that we hear a
lot but yeah the hardest one was uh this
fat [ __ ] oh yeah i remember
this about this bad [ __ ]
and you have to do it without laughing
and is there um how long can you take
before you say it like i noticed that
you you sal doesn't you could take it
you could take a minute
but i found the longer you take the
harder oh really oh really harder again
because you're thinking about
anticipation that's exactly right um
and what are your i i imagine your
family is all very close
yeah what what do your siblings think of
what you do are they ever afraid that
they're gonna be roped into the uh no
they've gotten in in a little bit you
know my daughter's been roped in a
little bit sounds dad they're always
friends
yeah yeah we get him all the time he's
on speed dial i love it he calls us
sometimes he's like i got an idea
he's the best he's awesome who were your
influences as a kid like who did you
watch growing up no brooks yeah yeah mel
brooks loved uh the zucker brothers you
know yeah airplane those movies i loved
uh
you know i i always loved physical
comedy yeah i was one of my biggest cow
burnett yes hands down car brunette show
laughing uh was huge for me like all
that old school comedy stuff but then
like i like i enjoyed stand up too
richard jenny was my friend maybe my
father him tim allen we used to watch
all that you watched with your dad and
my dad yeah that's cool so that sort of
stuff i loved but i was always physical
comedy always movie i'm more of a laurel
and hearty did you get it yes yeah i got
into um
yeah i really liked it i love lucy you
know old school stuff like that but for
for the most part it was like the muppet
show oh yeah it was huge for me who was
your mother who was your father oh yeah
of course i love fozzie yeah he's my jam
and my son loves muppet babies and
fozzies oh really that's pretty cool
he's sick
my son's four my daughter's sick oh all
right uh that must be so cool to get to
introduce so cool you're kids
yeah yeah i love that and then my my
daughter is like a little bit of uh
starlet she loves to sing and loves that
loves the attention but then she
realizes and gets really nervous and
wants to hide so that's really cool but
i had really cool experience when we
played msg
when we played radio city i just was the
first time i brought my daughter and i
have a great picture at the end i
brought her out we just had had her and
i brought her out at the end and and i
just have a picture they grabbed a
picture of me and my fist off like
presenting her to the world oh that's my
symbol moment i was like
so that was really cool and then when we
played when we played madison square
garden i got to do the same thing with
my son oh that's i have a great photos
with my kids on that it's just like
great memories well she's been on the
show too yeah she's been on the show
yeah she's been down there and she's
good on the show she's great she's like
really she's great she's great yeah um i
i remember one where like you had to
have uh you had to be like terrible
parents that's is that hard it was a
parenting group yeah that was my
punishment they said they're like we got
your child actor and my daughter walks
through the door and i had to like i had
to they re pre-wrote all my questions
what i had to answer and they
one of the questions was they made me
say that he's like oh how do you get
discipline tips for your children i they
made me say i watch uh the dog whisperer
which says yeah and i had to take out a
bag of cheerios and treat it like treats
i had to make a roll over and she was
phenomenal she's just so fun and game
but she didn't know what's going on
she's like oh daddy's saying roll over
oh yeah oh she did it so naturally it's
like
she played it so well that like it
really reinforced that really the other
thing was because we spend a lot of time
we play a lot and stuff she's bad i bet
you must be that must have been you must
be a
fun dad yeah it's fun it's it's fun
because like the the with the world
shutting down we travel so much and
everything yeah and it works so much i
really didn't have you know if we're
gonna be honest and really have a good
relationship with my kids at all like
they didn't really know me that much
yeah literally two weeks before the
pandemic i was came home and my daughter
was really excited and we had a good day
and she goes daddy i love when you come
to visit and i was like i just ripped my
heart i was like i'm doing something
wrong here right and then fast forward
i'm just home with them and i got to
build this great relationship with them
so now going back now it's like okay now
i'm doing it it's a nice it's a really
foundation yeah it's a good foundation
so well thank god for the pendant i mean
that's really why i started it oh take
that out
what were the limitations then in terms
of doing the show during the pandemic
like what what were the difficulties
well a lot of the show is actually set
up for success with social distance and
just worked into it we present
presentations focus groups things of
that nature like we were able just to
lean into that really what went away was
walking into a supermarket tapping
somebody on the shoulder or being in the
park like that kind of just a random
stuff yeah we just figured out a
different way to do it and how do we
make like
a fake coffee shop or how do we make a
fake like just make these make these
scenarios with these people that we've
brought in yeah so and it was good it
helped us think of new ways to play and
when you were selling things were you
ever when you were you mentioned being a
salesman which is what you do so well on
the show you sell these weird even with
the potatoes it's like oh i'm just
you're making people laugh like you've
you're flipping the script um was there
ever a moment where you felt like i
could do this for my life were you happy
doing that or or were you always
thinking about i love comedy i love
sales and comedy was always kind of like
the side yeah it was like a hobby yeah
but then it presented when it presented
itself it's funny because everybody else
was actually able to keep their job oh
yeah i was the first one had to quit oh
that's funny so i was all in from the
beginning so we filmed the pilot on my
two-week vacation when i was working for
this baby store giggle uh-huh and i was
a personal shopper and their training
program manager so i would go to my
ceo's office i'm like hey i need i'm
gonna take my two-week vacation we're
filming this pilot for jokers so we
don't film the pilot and then they pick
it up they say okay you need six months
and i go and i'm like hey i'm going to
take a six month hiatus and just like so
you're quitting and i'm like no no no
i'll be back and she's like well no i
hope you don't have to come yeah yeah
and she said she said but if you do
there'll be a place here for you but it
won't be this job uh-huh because i had
to replace you and i was like okay so
then it just so i you were all in wow
but which is good because i really i
always wanted to direct always you know
that's my i will be a director like
that's what i want to do so this is kind
of like a little detour a little
detour um but like that's what i want to
do so i got fell into the production
part of it really took to the production
part show running like learning all that
part of it
when they do the behind the scenes yeah
like you're yeah i i very much became
the part of that which i really it
interested me yeah and it also helped
the show because it had our voice in it
totally you know so it was really good
oh that's great what kind of stuff do
you want to draw do you have something
in mind yeah that's your first yeah yeah
i do i have con i just actually we
talked about when i moved out here i had
written a short film 13 years ago and i
just filmed it in may oh no which is
awesome i just finished it it was great
oh that's great
back in yeah in upstate new york yeah i
did two overnight and overnight shoot of
uh i think it's an eight-minute short
it's great i love it it came really good
oh good i'm really happy with it how do
people see it um it's not out yet okay
yeah so well i'm actually having
meetings about that with other people
right now which is cool so it's fun like
to do it i really just did it because it
was a calling card because when i
started talking to people about want to
direct and having it out there like okay
what do you have yeah and i only i
didn't have something i i've had this
great that i was sitting on and i just
needed time to do it and i found the
time and i was like oh great well that's
the other thing you guys are all such i
said this to sell he wouldn't accept the
compliment but like you're such good
actors you i mean you have to be
well i i think you are i mean i really
do think you are that you have no you
you're the good actor in the room i
don't think so i mean like you have to
be because all it is is being present to
a scenario to a situation and and
committing to something i mean you of
all are so committed the commitment
levels are a problem yeah the
memorization and being comfortable in
that skin is a little different well
it's just that's just mechanics but yeah
i mean what you guys do is like you have
to convince if anything it's harder you
have to like convince people that you
are existing in the world
is
ridiculous in the real world i never
thought of it that way dr shrimp puerto
rico like you have to like that person
you have to convince people that you
think stack your shrimp puerto rico
might be in a room
that's true that's very true i could
never do that we should win in oscar i
see what you're saying yes yes uh has it
made you more bold in life
yeah yeah well i've always been pretty
bold but but like now it's just it's
just crazy it's funny because like with
some stuff
like with the fame is kind of annoying
because like you can't really do it you
want to do it anymore yeah right so like
i used to always do this bit with sal
whenever we walked into a store like
shopping i'd yell yeah what's the
discount what's the action like i would
come in right away talk who's the
manager what am i talking i need 20 off
i'm going to do some damage in here like
i would do that any store any or
anywhere anywhere because i know rita
i've been working retail forever it's
all bs everybody can mark down whatever
the hell they want there's a code for
something like don't don't tell me
there's not so i would just go into
every store and
ten times out of ten i would get a
discount right all right so
now when i do it it's like it's uh now i
call it the celebrity discount
and he's like dude you can't ask for a
celebrity
like joke around but like that was some
of my favorite jokes to do because yeah
people kind of expect it for you or you
get away with more because i know you're
in the eye but it was fun for me when i
was i know exactly isn't that kind of
disappointing when you get away with
i've had that because i used to love
this why also why i love the show i
loved messing with i loved attempting to
do what you guys do so well like you
guys take it to elevate it to an art
form i think but like i've always loved
doing that like messing with the
societal norms or whatever but like uh i
remembered that moment of where i
couldn't really do that anymore where it
wasn't as easy to do it right anyway
where people would and i i remember the
feeling of somebody laughing
uh because they right
yeah they recognize yeah and it's right
it's disappointing it's right you're
like oh man no i wanted to be some
element of like i shouldn't be doing
this yeah yeah farting in church yeah
that's exactly right yeah the church
life is that that's good it's the best
bits in church were always so fun
because it was like yeah you're not
supposed to do that the stakes are
really high yeah well i thought the guys
got me at my uh
sorry about my grandmother's uh my
grandmother's uh funeral we were all
pretty close to my grandma too and i'm
given the eulogy and somebody's cell
phone goes off during the yoga is dead
quiet but it's i'm not kidding it's the
theme to halloween no
so immediately i lock eyes with sal
murray in the back and i'm like look at
them and i'm talking that's why you were
doing the show and no oh oh no this was
an accident
and the person wouldn't answer their
phone and sal it just starts like this
so i thought it was them and i'm like
these guys there's nothing sacred right
so then after did you address it during
the eulogy no i just let it happen
because i a moment it was for me i was
like oh these guys definitely did it but
i was like if it wasn't them it's really
going to embarrass somebody just let it
go yeah so after i go up to them and
sell my they were like it wasn't us we
swear we like we thought you set it up
to be a joke and i was like i didn't i
was like how great is that and then fast
forward to like season six we do the
punishment with sal's at a poetry
reading and his phone keeps going off
singing whose phone is ringing mine mine
and he can't answer it that's directly
influenced from our life oh that's you
know what i mean so like oh that poetry
reading was amazing
that we couldn't he couldn't answer it
all those people hated him hated him and
like that that's got to be hard for all
of you guys because you're all set you
all seem like really good people and
like they don't want to hurt people but
like sal had to [ __ ] on other people's
poems uh-huh that was um because sal in
particular is like seems like such a
sensitive guy
but you don't even realize like what you
think people hold sacred like one of
sal's biggest ones that we couldn't
believe it went that way was when he had
to keep yelling bingo in a bingo ball
with all these blue hairs in connecticut
and
he was dude they were out for blood
they were like shut down one person told
me they were gonna stab him like it was
insanity it was absolute mayhem and sal
was like dude i'm gonna get shipped out
here it was craziness a thousand blue
hairs playing bingo
sal's life is on the line
that's right that was
yeah you um
yeah
it must be surprising when you realize
like the stakes for other people yeah
because it did use like it's a bingo
game but like
this is bingo this is sunday big brother
sunday bingo get out yeah um oh man
that's really funny uh i i i want to get
back to um the adopt-o-shop uh charities
that you work with how many right
because i know so you say you have nine
i have nine right now nine right now and
what's the most you've ever had at one
time ten
yeah we just lost bella cheesecake oh
yeah we have another cheesecake for hot
minute she stopped by so i have uh
cannoli biscotti oh yeah they're all
yeah yeah cannoli biscotti tartufo uh
spamoni napoleon panna cotta
ganache
uh strufela those are my nine and we had
bella cheesecake we actually threw this
my aunt she was on her way out my aunt
just needed somebody she couldn't take
care of her anymore so we had her for
about a week uh and we just all dogs all
dogs yeah one boy napoleon's the only
boy uh-huh it's kind of hard when you
have but a pack mentality is awesome
like they just come in and they all just
follow each other but scotty's the mama
bear yeah is that a big one uh no
biscotti my biggest one is strooflus
she's 50 pounds but the rest are all
like small little white doggy kind of
deals an ex-girlfriend um had else
friend of the show maggie q had had
seven uh dogs i remember when we were
together and and the um
the one they're all big all big
and uh the one that like like ran the
roost the the alpha was mr p who was
this tiny little chihuahua it was the
funniest crazy thing to see the dynamic
yeah this thing would just like kind of
go around
it's just so weird the way dogs that
they're they're just nature and
everything it's just insane when you
introduce a new one it's it's crazy when
you're a kid were you like we had one
dog i had one dog for 17 years midnight
yeah i got we got it when i was one we
had to put her down when i was 17. oh
that's huge especially little schnauzer
who ran the roost
my parents just opened the door in the
morning she would leave she'd come back
at night to get fed like we didn't know
what she did around the world fantastic
it was like feral by day it was crazy
yeah my father one day was driving home
and on harbor road where i lived there
was a pothole and he looked and the dog
was sleeping in the pothole she was like
taking a nap and i was like oh so you
have to go get a big rock and put like a
rocket
what did your dad do oh my dad was
insurance salesman uh okay it was a vice
president of insurance company wow so
it's in your blood yeah for sure yeah
for sure yeah yeah this must go without
saying but like he i bet he'd be really
yeah thrilled to see yeah i think i
think yeah i think he'd be proud of the
guy it's funny because i only had him
until i was 18. yeah so i've had him you
know less than half my life yeah just
the impact they make so that's how i
learn about you know
the time you have yeah the you know
parenting and all that stuff that really
influences the way i think about it like
i always always have a joke with the guy
i'm like yeah i'm on my way out guys
like we always make that joke i'm not
afraid of it like it's like that's the
way it is you know legacy and being the
best person you could be and stuff like
that well so in that sense i must give
you a healthy outlet for sure
yeah i do have a healthy outlook i have
well it's funny because sal always loves
me because you either have it completely
right or completely wrong i don't know
which it is like you should not be this
comfortable with it yeah yeah yeah right
he said you know but i like you know we
always joke about you know my parents
and death and stuff and it doesn't
matter like my kids know about death
might you know really yeah because my
you know when my dogs die like okay
i've had 12 dogs over the course well
that's how i was introduced to it
because i had so many animals growing up
so i had to kind of understand i had to
have some understanding of it but but
how do you
how do you explain that to a kid like
how do you well i you just talk openly
right you know my son remo calls we have
pictures of my mom up at the house
whatever he's like he calls out the dead
grandma
he's like oh yeah when i tell a story
and he's like was that grandma a dead
grandma like really lame you know but
you know what would she laugh at that i
mean like hundred percent yeah like we
used to make jokes about my dad with her
you know yeah so it was always it was it
was never you know taboo thing was
always you know laughter's healing in my
family kind of deal life could be a
dream
[Music]
sweetheart the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wandery plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
[Music]
what is your most commonly used emoji
would you say your go-to emoji i don't
really use emojis never no hardly use
emojis really yeah i have a hatred for
emojis oh wow okay hatred yeah i'm sorry
wow it's weird that you brought that
trigger
people oh yeah wow
joe's got one thing
do not mention the emoji
uh he will get buried you know what i do
i do yeah i get buried i handle the face
you know what you know what's funny like
i'll use them ironically and one i do
use a lot is the woman that's like oh
yeah okay i don't know
ironic use still counts
i guess i use it but it's few and far
between okay uh if you could be a
professional athlete what sport would
you play look at me nothing well
if you had to if someone if i my back of
the club some deranged billionaire was
like do it yeah i'm a pretty i'm pretty
bad ass bowler oh okay i would bowl okay
cool what sport would you consider that
a sport i think so yeah i think it is a
sport yeah yeah uh what is your do you
have it like a high score 288 oh just in
high school really yeah i was on the
high school bowling league it's been a
while like i don't really roll 288's
anymore that was my highest are you a
germaphobe do you have any no so
my thing was always the holes yeah yeah
you gotta you gotta have your own ball
though yes that's true that's it that's
what the professionals do oh that's true
yeah have you been uh bowling since yeah
we just went pretty recently oh really
yeah my niece's nephew took my uh my
daughter it was fun
do you hang out with the guys off the
show sal kind of mentioned that you
occasionally but like for the most you
guys work together some time yeah when
we're on the road we do like it's like
when it's like you want to go shopping
your friends are there you want to go to
a movie your friends yeah yeah but when
you're home like you're trying to see
your either your other friends right you
know what i mean it's like it's funny
because they're non-tv you're not tv
friends but during the summer like we go
to each other's maybe you know for a
barbecue like once each house over the
summer you know so like four or five
times did murray's lawn grow back in
yeah barely yeah like literally just now
his curb is still pink like this part of
his curve that's just like still pink
like there's no way it's coming out i i
love how proud he is he is of his like
property yeah and i love that it plays
on his vanity
yeah i'm like your yard like he's like
it's a property i like your yard dude
it's pretty big yeah it is pretty big um
uh that's really funny who if you could
oh and you guys are speaking of uh tour
you're you're going on tour this fall
yeah right just announce it yeah great
uh in september you started we're
starting to start in uh november
november 17th our first one yeah god i'd
like to see that because i'm curious i'm
curious how you incorporate a live
this show into a live yeah it's it's
more like the hanging out part of it
where we tell stories about each other's
lives but there's also that's great a
lot of video elements it's multimedia
it's got it's real fun okay november uh
all over the country oh yeah we just
launched them so we're just we just
ruined at least 40 dates i think oh
great starting in november if you could
have one snack food for the rest of your
life i know by the way sal does a great
uh snack uh taste buds his podcast is so
great it's so funny uh that's based on
that's based on so many i mean sal and
i've also had so many conversations
about that but i could debate snacks
foods like we we had a tour bus once we
got into it about uh what was the best
uh yeah it was the best um el fudge uh
versus uh you know uh a chips ahoy yeah
yeah but for me uh my favorite snack
food i would probably have to go with
like a hostess cupcake oh really yeah no
kidding yeah of course if we're talking
like we're talking like a snack food
from the yeah but if it's not it's a
cannoli it's a it's a italian pastry
it's a canola oh it's gonna say cause
you are like a real pastry guy that's my
deal what is there a canola you want to
promote is there a place about staten
island is it would it be place down by
me st rocco's bakery really phenomenal
yeah okay i go there every sunday
morning a particular flavor of cannoli
uh right just straight up standard issue
yeah they make a great they make a great
lobster tail too if you're into it okay
and how close is that to a cheesecake is
that my brother's been trying to get me
to he's been trying to turn me off did
you just ask me how close a cannoli is
to it well i mean in terms of because i
have a problem with the cheese element
oh i got to the ricotta element yeah
that sounds like that sounds like a
banana like movie you wouldn't actually
make an action film
[Laughter]
movies what is your favorite movie
sequel of all time the sequel yeah oh
that's a good one uh
well i mean godfather two definitely
writes it because it's fantastic i feel
like that's that is the answer everybody
yeah oh you know what i really enjoyed
john wick too oh really yeah okay i
gotta see it i like john wick i can't
believe i've never seen john wayne the
john wick movies are they're fun right
yeah and what's the movie you really
want to introduce uh your son and your
daughter too well we just started
dabbling into some of the star wars
stuff she's a little young which is fun
but i can't wait till they get into some
of the marvel stuff i love all them oh
you do
but like my favorite one for them to
watch which i really think they'll like
because they both are like adventurous
too i goonies is the one for me that
yeah i want to watch
it's either that or galaxy quest oh yeah
yeah
oh i loved galaxy questions you know i i
don't know if i shouldn't say this but
they're doing a serie a galaxy quest
like limited series shut up yes simon
pegg is writing it
shhh exciting yeah yeah simon just said
he texted me and said what's your
character i was like i'm wondering i
hope i'm in it so and he said what's
your character's last name i was like oh
good phenomenal i'm excited i'm so
excited about that and the goonies i've
been thinking about a lot lately because
uh sadly richard donner
died um uh superman i i need to rewatch
that his superman oh yeah such a great
director yeah yeah um yeah i mean
goonies for me it was like because i was
always that adventure like kind of
totally kid too so that was that it was
just spoke to my soul yeah i can't wait
for uh for my kids to watch yeah i bet
oh that'll be so fun it makes me want to
have kids
you know you borrow mine okay good all
right i'll let you know when we're gonna
watch if you come on by okay okay
perfect who's this guy he just wants to
have the experience my friend justin
yeah yeah don't worry you're drinking
water
[Laughter]
he keeps staring at me um what's your
what is your go-to karaoke song um i'm
known for my hype man skills oh yeah so
he'll be like flavorful yeah yeah i'm
like i'm uh joint pain
okay yeah come on come on yeah here we
go here we go like that's me that's
that's my guy that's where i live okay
um who was your first celebrity crush
that you remember like the the one that
made it christmas carpenter oh yeah i
would probably say yeah from buffy uh
yeah she was up there for me uh i didn't
watch buffy uh yeah
she was on angel too but i i i just
remember loving her but alyssa milano
for sure come from staten island you
know for sure yeah yeah definitely one
of my celebrity crushes yo she was great
uh do you have any tattoos i do not oh
that sounds story is amazing yeah
[ __ ] jade
that's great that was brilliant um
uh if you had to get one what would it
be where i'd probably get my m if i had
to i'd probably get my children's
initials inside of a cannoli
i feel like it's everything that and
like there's a poor prince
that's great uh what is your favorite
fruit my favorite fruit's an apricot oh
okay that was a quick answer yeah i feel
like it's underused yeah yeah you know
what i why though because there was an
apricot in my room okay a hotel and i
had it this morning it was delicious i
mean a ripe plum is also good i'm
thinking
my grandfather had an orchard out here
kidding property he had a huge he had a
huge like garden he grew everything
that's property
yeah he had like uh he had like
everything from prickly pears to like
watermelon and strawberry like he grew
everything that's amazing your
grandfather my grandfather yeah oh why
in l.a yeah he lived uh yeah he lived in
the valley oh that's so cool
what happened to the farm they sold
unfortunately they still didn't move
back to new york before anybody would
have been able to buy it like i would
have isn't that i drove by it not too
long ago i drove by like i was out here
about six months ago for some meetings
or something and i was in the va i was
like you know what i'm gonna drive by so
i texted my sister and she knew the
address and i drove by and it kind of
the house was there oh really i could
see it and i kind of like they changed
where the front door was and stuff so i
could kind of like still get a feel for
isn't that funny do you believe in
ghosts uh yeah ish
i believe in i believe in uh i don't
think people just go away yeah you know
but i just heard this thing from a
stand-up that was really funny is i
never hear about modern ghosts it's like
always somebody from the
who died in like 1700s yeah like nobody
hears me does it take a while to like
get your credentials yeah so i don't
know that ghost is wearing a charles
barkley jersey i i don't know
he's like like he's like a late 90s
ghost what's that you know he's got
nike's on yeah i i i after like i feel
like you don't want to forget people and
i think you make connections a lot too
yeah but there have been some things in
my life that i was like oh that's too
weird with people who have passed my
father especially like after some stuff
i was like oh that's a little weird
that's been coming up a lot on the show
things in nature i've felt uh when
michael's my grandma died recently and
um we were really close uh italian she
was uh jody finale uh she was the best
but she she was on the show she was oh
so the friend of the show yeah so people
feel like you know it's nice they like
kind of feel like you know and they did
she was really great but um
she uh yeah i keep seeing her there are
moments
things you mentioned yeah you'll you'll
do i don't know if it's because you're
you're putting it out there i don't know
or maybe you're putting it out there and
you're open to it yeah yeah that could
be part of it but you've definitely felt
things 100 yeah i was one of the
weirdest experience of my life i'm
driving in philadelphia i worked in
philly after my dad had passed away and
i was thinking about him and my window
was open for some reason i was thinking
about giving him a hug for some reason i
focused on an acorn in a parking lot on
in a tree
for no reason at all the acorn i'm
driving like 20 miles an hour through
like a parking lot the acorn falls out
of the tree bounces and comes in my open
window and i catch it like this like
when you hug somebody i still have the
acorn i was like that is you can't
explain that joe just put his cheek to
his yeah
he must have been young yeah yeah he
died he was 56 jesus yeah
wow and was it sudden was it that uh
yeah he they gave him he had pancreatic
cancer they gave him the game six months
he gave him three months he got six out
of it um and but like in my dad fashion
like as soon as he found out he had it
yeah he's like we're going to vegas he
took the whole family to vegas no you
maybe get a fake id so you could play
blackjack equipment yeah yeah
that's like one of the best trips ever
oh my gosh i was like such a great like
you know memory guy yeah yeah and then
he was it he was at home too so it was
good like they didn't want to he talked
to the doctor and they're like this you
know this is 95. yeah you know they're
nowhere near with cancer yeah they were
and he was like they're like well do the
chemo belong he's he looked at me said
look i'm looking for quality not
quantity wow he's like what are we
talking about here and they're like you
know maybe you get a year it's like a
year sick or you're three months healthy
yeah and then just he's like i'm doing
it that way really and he had started he
had such peace with it that he made
everybody comfortable about it really he
was like at home and he was just like he
was just great the way he handled it was
just like i think that's part of it that
embodies me about like yeah the no fear
of it grace in death is like what a gift
yeah to to yeah and to be there with him
there all the way to the end it was just
like you know you're on that journey
with them
man
to be comforted by the person who is was
insane like people would come crying
into his room and i'm like he's the one
dying
wow
i would aspire to be i mean that's what
you aspire to be like right and the
other side of it was my mom so my dad
had the strong thing and my mom was
always like my mom was such a
firecracker and she was like i don't
want to get old i never wanted to get
all she's like she'd always put that out
there in the university i don't want to
get old i want to be decrepit she was
always like she was like a fun 67 68 she
wasn't she was just always like loud fun
working independent like that kind of
thing you know
yeah
you know she literally like went in her
sleep like one night and it was like
gone yeah like we got the phone call and
we went to the hospital and she was gone
and i was like that's it true drop the
mic um
where were we what a great digression uh
who would you want to play you in your
biopic joe you yeah yeah you're the only
choice yeah yeah i don't know if i have
the balls my balls are weird i mean you
know what i get all the time that kind
of uh steve carell looks like me
yeah yeah
oh for sure
uh i bet he didn't really enjoy playing
he watched the show we found out on
twitter on twitter we found out i would
go and obama and they uh the
fan comes in from the street and um you
know i'm shopping and they say okay take
a picture i said yeah i take a picture
with them and i'm buying a bunch of food
because my wife's in the car and
pregnant she was hungry on the way back
so i'm like okay i buy a bunch of food
and the woman at the checkout as i check
out she's like i just wanted to say and
uh you know i'm a huge fan to me and i
was like oh thank you she's like yeah i
loved evan almighty and the office and i
was like
does this woman think i'm there so i was
like
i don't sound like i'm sorry i smile
yeah yeah
you get a quick picture and then she
everybody comes out i get behind me i
take a picture with the whole group and
then i post it on twitter and i'm like
hey thanks for the free sandwich they
thought i was you and i tag a minute and
he said no problem thanks for the laughs
oh that's awesome and the company
tweets hey uh we'll give you a black
card mr carrell uh you could uh next
lunch is on us whatever you want and i
tweeted back what are you talking about
where's my black card
so he got like free for life
well it's a pretentious sandwich
well now you don't get anything
you mentioned favorite muppet which is
one of our questions uh is fozzie um
what's your favorite muppet movie what's
the one that you want to introduce to
your kids oh the caper right the crown
man sure charles grodin what a lost sure
yeah he was so good in that he's in one
of my favorite movies ever uh um with uh
with de niro midnight and ron's
phenomena i just rewatched it not too
long ago uh totally holds up he's so fun
to watch i've been watching him on uh
old talk shows like him on letterman and
yeah where he's just playing like that
curmudgeonly uh persona he's talking
about i mean commitment yeah sure that's
joe gatto level um
um what is your go-to pizza topping um
for me a black olive i like a good black
really yeah i'll do a big olive uh and
do you have a pizza place in new york
that you love i have uh well new york
new york pizza is fantastic yeah i just
love new york pizza overall i mean but
by by me there's a place called uh
phil's okay which makes a drunken
sicilian it's called it's a sicilian
pizza with uh penne
vodka sauce oh wait instead yeah which
is phenomenal where is that
it's in phil it's phil's in uh glen cove
new york glenn cove okay cool um dogs
are cats you prefer i mean what are we
doing here
on there i will put it out here though
you know this and this is something
that's dear to my heart yeah let's talk
about it okay i don't not like cats okay
all right i don't want to be that you
know i'm not a person dog or cat guy
okay good it's a stigma that needs to go
away i'm not gonna love her i'm just
promoting this stuff all right i don't
want you to be part of the problem i'm
looking to be part of solution mr long
okay what other animals let's throw in a
chinchilla oh man
don't get me started okay they're
basically they're cute they're cute rats
like nobody wants you like nutrients
yeah it's like a guinea pig yeah squeeze
it down it's a rat that's got a good
haircut i'm not into it but for me a
parakeet or any of the flight birds i'm
a fan of i love a parrot i had african
grey for a little bit oh really yeah
what what what other non-uh dog another
non-dogs uh you know i i rescue a lot of
things you could you could be surprised
when you dress yeah out there yeah yeah
i do uh i never gotten a fish no
reptiles and reptiles were not that i
don't like them but it's not i'm more of
a cuddly yeah kind of guy yeah you know
like a good cuddle well that's your bed
seems so like yeah furry and it's crazy
what are the three that don't sleep on
there the old ones oh yeah panna cotta
and ganache
they're they're on the floor well panda
hannah can't see so she's gonna know why
so uh panda can't see and kata's got no
eyes kata's got no eyes
but phenomenal life she lives she loves
belly rubs yeah but they just walk off
the bed so they can't stop laughing at
them
they have to stay off they have to stay
off the bed because they just walk
around walk the plank
that's funny and sad yeah uh again you
probably will object to this but beatles
are the rolling stones i don't really
know music
what yeah i'm not really i don't really
know much music so um the beatles the
rolling stones i don't think i can name
a rolling stone song you're kidding uh a
single song i don't think i can to shame
you but no it's what about a beatles
song beatle song yeah right the el
submarine in this thing yes
i am you know i just got i just got into
uh johnny cash a little bit oh yeah um
by accident because it was on a playlist
i realized but i do i do i probably had
to pick one say the beatles okay yeah i
probably know more beetle songs than i
do rolling ones yeah
uh i'm more of a pop music a guy or an
oldies like do what beef 1950s oh okay
that's why i listened to growing up with
my parents and stuff oh yeah yeah that's
funny me too that's what started me in
like more uh you're like a big music guy
i love music but it was stand by me it
was the soundtrack for stand by me i
remember getting and like that kind of
opened up everything um yeah uh seinfeld
do you like do you watch tv are you
seinfeld or friends seinfeld yeah yeah
yeah
yeah sale answered it the same way um
i i imagine sal and i probably have the
most it's so funny because sal and i
really get into it when it comes to
music because sal knows like every music
but he knows like the obscure ones too
and it gets so annoying he'll be like he
shames all the time me and murray and
he'll be like how could you not how do
you not know funky coco in the pop-pop
like like i'm like nobody knows funky go
go in the papa he's like kidding me he's
like they sang wandango i'm like what
are you talking about no one knows the
words that are coming out of your mouth
that's so he goes i think it's indignant
like he's very very uppity with it i bet
yeah yeah yeah uh ketchup or mustard do
you prefer uh ketchup uh and i put both
on i put both on a veggie hot dog though
you too i throw a relish in a sauerkraut
on there too i love the fixins what's a
good uh non-meat um hot dog hamburger oh
beyond the beyond brand i love that yeah
yeah beyond sausages for fake sausage
and pepper so good i know the beyond is
really good and yeah of course we keep
talking about being in la what's um
what's a great vegetarian vegan place in
la uh crossroads the restaurant is
phenomenal yeah but i love that uh
phenomenal yeah they make a great like i
you know i grew up on italian food and i
was like wow this is phenomenal oh
that's good to know um and
joe what are two adjectives you would
like people to use to describe you after
you've gone we're talking talking about
it like you're eulogy like little j remo
is given i would say uh we i would say
kind and brave yeah those are we have a
mantra in the gatto house be brave be
kind be a gatto and we say it every day
before the kids go to school and that's
no kidding that we try to well you
embody that i i think both of those
virtues you are a true it have been so
fun to watch on that show and
i i just love i love it so much i'm i'm
so appreciative of it that's great well
you've given me years of i owe you years
of entertainment no you guys are
phenomenal you're uh yeah it's been such
a joy so thank you and thank all the
thank murray and q i gotta have them on
the show yeah i'm sure they'll hit you
up next i mean you start with sal you
know so now you're just working down the
ladder
[Laughter]
at the end we're going to ask you you're
going to rate us and i'll say oh yeah
okay all right compared to sal how did i
do it because that was a good one i
don't know it was a good one this was
great it was it's so fun i just it again
like i you guys are so easy to talk to
but it um and i'm glad because i i i
could have gone into this like knowing
you or thinking i know you the way i do
and then
i don't know you're like uptight and
like what a really big huge rolling
stones fan
yeah all and then you come to find out
it was all just for the show
but uh
no you guys are great i'm really murray
take off your wigs um no i i really
appreciate it uh all the laughs thanks
so much for having me thanks joe
so so that just happened that just
happened
yeah that just happened
kind of like that he's got a great i
love don't you look it's phenomenal i
love it phenomenal well she says
phenomenal oh my god it's you got to try
the truth okay
yeah these cannolis are the most
phenomenal they're the most you got to
get them in your mouth they're
phenomenal you know who would um he's
got like a vince and i was thinking that
because vince is the only other person
who uses that word yes so freely it's
phenomenal phenomenal he does that's one
of my favorite things he does when he
eats a lot in wedding crashes he's such
a funny eater that wedding montage of
winning crashers i think brilliant might
be the best movie montage
comedy movie montage of all time you
don't have to think that the wedding
montage in wedding crush is the best
movie montage what did you say yes i
mean what's better than that oh no too
and to a song that i previously had
always been annoyed by uh yeah you
should get up and generally shout yeah
it's annoying i don't like being told
what to do in a song you know like i'm
not gonna you don't like the ymca
i kind of like ymca actually i was just
gonna say it's annoying that that dance
accompanies you know why mca but they
don't the song itself doesn't tell you
to do that with your hands that's true
that's true they're not forcing you
whereas this is like a little bit softer
now a little bit louder now you gotta
like it's annoying yeah the wave is
annoying do you hate when there's their
song like put your hands in the air and
wave them like you just don't care do
you ever like feel the wave is annoying
yeah
also uh sweet caroline but i do it i do
you know what's the most annoying part
of sweet caroline
yeah yeah
what's wrong
so we're being so negative you know one
of the funniest things jonah did let's
make it more positive i remember when
jonah used to sing that song when it was
we do karaoke
and instead of pom pom bomb he go [ __ ]
you dad
i always think of that now
it was one of the funniest things and
it's something that's so funny that it
like has stayed with me this whole
because he didn't have a bad
relationship with his dad it was just
like a fight shout out to rich feldman
it's just a really funny random thing to
say oh man it made me laugh so hard
still does
[ __ ] you dad good times never because it
was so like positive and buoyant like he
and he did it with a big smile
joe gatto joe catto man what and what a
great guy god it really does it did seem
like you knew him
very surprising that you didn't i know
but he seemed like a ketchup it seemed
like one of the life is short episodes
that's just more of a ketchup oh well it
makes sense from my end i guess just
because like we said i've been watching
so much of him and i just i i felt like
i knew him but for him
you know he had much less exposure to me
although that's true but he he has such
a natural people-person quality to him
or is this an arrogant assumption um
that he because i knew i knew he had
been listening to the show oh i listened
to the show oh really in fact he reached
out on instagram i don't want to out him
this might sound lame but like it was so
flattering i was it meant a lot to me
that he i think he must have heard us
talk about how much we love the show and
so he reached out and he was like hey i
saw he was following me on instagram and
we like chatted on instagram that's cool
yeah
yeah he he i think likes the show i
think i i don't want to
if he's listening now and he's like what
was he talking about i mean
i haven't listened to the show oh it's
funny anyway he's we love you joe and um
and and
so i mean murr and and um you're next
quinn i mean like brian those guys have
to come on so if they're listening which
they should be they should be supporting
a fellow joker it's he's such a
fascinating guy because he's like such a
guy's guy you know he comes across as
such a guy like a guy but he has such
sensitivities
and he doesn't um he knows nothing about
sports or
music and he doesn't drink or do any
drugs or isn't that amazing how why he
doesn't drink yeah yeah really moving
he's such a like but there's something
so sensitive about him too and like and
compassionate
not drinking or doing drugs now you know
he's in his 40s
to me that's much less impressive i know
than avoiding it during those years
those like insecure years it's true the
fact that he
was as amiable and fun and gregarious
then like in high school and college
totally sober
speaks to how naturally confident he is
totally i mean that that's an incredible
amount of confidence required also to do
all that sober i know to do those bits
to like [ __ ] with people i know that's
wild well he kind of alluded to this i
don't know how directly he addressed it
but he said i wondered if because he
suffered that kind of a loss when he was
younger that things took on a whole new
meaning i mean like
the world was he saw through a different
lens um and
he had more courage i guess i mean to do
things like that like it this the stakes
uh it just everything is the stakes are
lowered you under or it's just like in
his dna yeah like his dad was this
amazing salesman and right right i mean
he has that
i'm not discounted no no no i'm sure
it's a combination yeah they're up right
from that that stock yeah i'm just going
to go up make the sale talk to you i've
never been scared on impractical jokers
all four of those guys are like they're
all extremely
brave in their own way but
i would say he more than the others has
a fearlessness
that is
it it's like unparalleled you know he
that guy
does does the craziest [ __ ] and he does
it like he commits
so much to the most absurd things that
he gets away with almost anything that's
true people just eat it up accept it
yeah i think the reason that show is as
effective as it is is because it's the
perfect combination of
funny and loving yeah yes like they love
each other and they're nice people
but if they weren't as nice and if they
like messed with people strangers more
in like a meaner way yeah i don't think
that show would be nearly as good well
it's funny because i've seen like
different incarnations of that show like
different attempts at that there was one
on recently i don't want to mention by
name but i i i think was comedy central
they've tried that that formula a few
other times and it usually has an
element of that of kind of like
snarkiness or like net you know even
like punk had a little bit of that was
like you start to feel bad for the for
the person at a certain point but you're
right they never veer into that that's
the genius of the shooks those guys are
so nice if anything they tease
themselves they make fun of me right i
love how he makes fun of murph for
referring to his property as his
property instead of his yard like his
property
it's such a that's such a subtle thing
but i i know what he's saying it's
really funny i know well that's the
thing those guys have i really share
maybe this is an arrogant thing to say
like i really like them because i feel
like i share such as so we both share
such a similar sense but that's such a
great thing and friendship you know
where you can
bust each other's balls and you can
tease each other and and know each
other's weaknesses and sometimes exploit
those weaknesses and it's never mean
it's like all done in love well
especially now like when so many people
can't take jokes the way they used to
like it's so nice that those guys can
take jobs and it's such a good thing to
like remind the world that it's okay to
do it's okay to be like offend your
friend a little bit exactly you know it
it it
helps you grow i think and it and and
like you discover the boundaries of your
own humor
you know it's like if i i i they all
have their line but like it's much
further than most people's lives oh my
god like they do [ __ ] during funerals i
know and that was a funny story that
this story about that uh the long game
bit he did with
valerie signed him up for all those
things
over the course of years
that is so funny and like knowing full
well that he probably wouldn't be there
for the reveal i know that's a true
uh clown and i mean that in the most
like affectionate way that's somebody
who just has a spirit of like values
humor and uh there's a over everything
else you know there's like a real
pla such a playfulness to him yeah oh my
god he is he is like a true
child
in in the best way
yeah in the pl in the most playful like
pure way he just like love he lives for
the joke it's like some of those people
who like never fully and i mean this in
the best way too that you never fully
grow up you know you still you always
retain that childhood thing you know
that like
fun like playful yes in a sense you know
qualities that most people associate
more with children yeah um but should be
valued in adults
yes should be like uh
cultivated it should be encouraged and i
think
i think it also makes the well we've
talked about this it makes the best
actors i think joe is actually really
great i think they're all like i know he
couldn't really accept that compliment
but i completely agreed with you yeah he
he really is oh yeah that's what they're
doing in in in these bits like they're
of course he's completely convincing
yeah also impressive that he sleeps with
six dogs in his bed yes
how i know how do you get up to pee i
don't know how you do that without
waking one of them up
that's i mean that's commitment
he i think he loves dogs more than
anyone i've ever met
so uh yeah which is also indicative of
like house what a sweet like sensitive
person he is i like how he has that
family like motto that they all or
mantra that they repeat like um if you
know what it is but they refer to
themselves as kind and brave yeah and
it's like of course what better words to
describe that guy i know and i'm sure
his kids are going to be kind and brave
i know things to aspire to yep and
things that he really you're right
really embodies let's read a letter okay
this is from ileana chase sorry do you
um make it extra crinkly when you grab
it just to like show that you're getting
something from subconsciously did i did
it sound like that i've thought this
before but i've never said anything oh
really let me try to do that again i'm
going to try it again
let's read a letter
no maybe it's just it's paper i mean
like it's paper paper i mean here's me
trying to do it like soft is that the
note this was two i'll do it stop okay
take three let's read a letter
your turn was soft too
that's soft okay okay this is thrilling
okay
uh
iliana hopefully joe's not listening now
that's a show you guys are doing ileana
chase
subject life is short let's travel
exclamation point mark dear justin and
christian we would like to start by
saying that we love your podcast we
we discovered it in june this year when
my husband
and i started traveling through the
united states oh that's the we
that's the we you and your brother
christian have accompanied us in our
travels for three months and 20 states
so far not counting canada that's
amazing three months that's so cool we
have caught up on almost every single
podcast and discovered new ones thanks
to your guests i.e minnie and rob well
we joined the peace corps wow a year and
a half ago good for you guys um but due
to the pandemic they've been delaying
our departure to thailand so we decided
to travel for a year sounds like a good
call to go to thailand i know
i know
beautiful there me too you both have to
want to go to thailand and admire people
who are in the peace corps we sold
everything we owned and packed our car
with our kayaks and essentials wow they
sound cool they sound very cool yeah we
embarked on this adventure of a lifetime
because life is too short after we
finish our us trip we'll be going to
costa rica and then south america okay
ileana hold on one second i'm gonna
recommend something to you to do in
custody because because i know you'll
love it i hope it's still there at the
base of mount arenal which is a
beautiful volcano there in the in the
mainland uh there is a place called
rancho margot it's um
it's a sustain it's a sustainable
they call it a resort but
um they grow your own food you cook your
own you'll love it um check it out
rancho margot and then south america god
i would
any recommendations for that no but i'm
dying to go to uh have you ever been to
uh south america remember when i planned
that machu picchu trip um no manchester
i planned a trip uh after uh a breakup i
was i'll really discover myself and um i
can't
i canceled it when i
i learned in more detail of the bathroom
situation
embarrassed to say this not not the
physical
um
difficulties
no of the climb that too brian our
mutual friend brian greenberg uh told me
that
about like altitude sickness and stuff
and i started researching that a little
bit um so that that worried me but that
wasn't a total deterrent the so you
cancel the trip you stayed home and
watched impractical jokers and stuff
exactly exactly it was you know what i'm
glad i did
back to ileana keep bringing joy and
laughter to our hearts ileana and
michael chase p.s we just saw lady of
the matter last week it was so funny yes
yes way to bury the lead
um
thank you ileana and michael
uh okay and she has yes would you rather
would you rather be stuck in a world
where you are famous but you cannot be
creative
someone else dictates what you do and
how you act or be able to create with
freedom but never get the credit for
your work or get recognized we've had
versions of this before
yeah excuse me um
we've had versions of this before it'd
definitely be for me
because i
i and i am i there are elements of being
famous of having recognition that are
definitely in the moment enjoyable and
um
uh do something for the you can feel
them make you feel momentarily but would
you say the negative components might
outweigh the positive components 100 i
would say for sure and it's only having
gone through it had i not had a taste of
it i might struggle with this question a
little bit more because there was a time
where i really coveted the trappings of
fame and all that and and it's
embarrassing to admit but it's true but
having experienced it but also
also in this scenario you can't be
famous and creative yeah so that is
dictates what you do and it's a
no-brainer oh yeah and for someone to
dictate how you act i don't even know
how that would work
well i guess it's a version of um
you know if you're on a reality show or
something something at some point oh
yeah i guess so hey will you be i think
that's kind of how they direct those
things like hey
they manipulate you but i guess but i
guess
you know as a reality contestant
unless you really want to be famous i
think there's a and which i think a lot
of them
are really driven by um i think this
question is it's easier to answer for
you having
tasted
some of that already yeah like you said
yeah i can answer it almost like on your
behalf because i've seen right i've seen
the negative components
even though i haven't really experienced
them
have yeah you have and you've also
experienced the like i would say a
negative part is like people saying bad
things about public people you don't
know saying that having a negative
opinions of you you've experienced that
i i
that's something to aspire to i think
getting to a point where
you care more about and focus more on
the positive things being said than the
negative that's that's i think that's
hard to do it is i aspire to that too
that is really hard to do because i
think there might be a part of i don't
know how deep i'm capable of getting on
this but like i think there is
a part of me that feels like undeserving
of that you know um is the imposter
syndrome so when i read something
negative it just kind of confirms like
oh yeah see i'm not right or i'm not
supposed to be doing it or whatever
it confirms some subconscious feeling
that i have something to talk about
therapy that's right um thank you eliana
yeah and um
congratulations on your cool life yeah i
know that sounds so fun uh yeah and good
luck noble i know fun and noble that's
the way to do it peace corps like joe
gatto fun and noble hey nice this is a
good letter for this episode it really
is and that was a good um
that that was a good wrap around what
would you call that a a reach around
yeah it was a great reach around joe
would like that joke um also if you guys
would like to write in the show no joke
that was a joke gatto
sorry about that our email address is
life is short at wondery.com
and uh we will talk to you all next week
and check out him practical jokers if
you haven't um
we love joe and we love you guys and um
thank you for listening talk to you next
week
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
life for sure is hosted by me justin
long it's co-hosted and produced by you
christian long it's also produced by
megan v monaco and katie v allen and the
senior producer is michelle
executive producer audio engineer sergio
enriquez and the audio engineer we just
said and now the executive producer
marshall louis the banner under which we
all do this the umbrella is wandery
[Music]
that's true this is a blimp isn't that
true
that's true a nutshell is not no it only
contains one thing yeah where and a
blimp only contains one thing what's in
a blimp do you even know
um i don't know it's helium and it's not
just helium right i don't know
but i don't know
doesn't that seem like something you
should know but who knows that what's in
a balloon i wish they
were
it'll be like it's things on like blimpy
sandwiches i know what's in a balloon
it's like whatever you want
what's in a blend pizza once in a place
the second option is what's what's best
in a plenty
you